thanks so much for joining us everybody
we have a lot of news to tell you about
Aretha Franklin will be laid to rest
this Friday in Detroit but special
viewings of the Queen of Soul began
today and that's why Michelle Turner is
in her hometown Michelle yeah keV a
star-studded lineup is expected to pay
their respects to Aretha Franklin this
week including Smokey Robinson Stevie
Wonder Jennifer Hudson and Faith Hill
now the fans out here will they have
lined up around the building to say
goodbye to the Queen of Soul who is
being remembered in royal fashion
the legendary singer was dressed
head-to-toe in one of her favorite
colors red a lace trim dress and high
heeled pumps her gold-plated casket
surrounded by dozens of roses and her
beloved gospel recordings played in the
background and this was a sight to
behold a Rita's casket arrived here in a
white 1940 Cadillac LaSalle hearse the
historic vehicle was also used to carry
the body of her father Reverend CL
Franklin and Civil Rights icon Rosa
Parks
Aretha who was 76 died of pancreatic
cancer 12 days ago today many of her
fans broke down in tears as they said
goodbye how many people do you think are
coming through to pay their respects to
her tens of thousands museum officials
asked mourners to put away their cell
phones before the viewing and not to
stop as they walked by the casket you
given her the diva treatment in the best
possible sense to send her home yes well
she was the best she deserves the best
she belongs to Detroit iconic voice she
is royalty meanwhile a free tribute
concert for Aretha will be held here in
Detroit on Thursday night among the
headliners Gladys Knight we spoke to her
last night in New York at the US Open
and she talked about a side of Aretha
that very few knew Aretha was very
shocked people just don't know that
about her you know it's just one of
those things we had that same Road to go
over the years
I saw her grow and hopefully she saw me
grow and her music is just you can't
just put it in a box you know it's a
reaper what are poised put up come on
girl and what a voice indeed now this
program here this is what friends family
and VIPs are being given when they come
to pay their respects to Aretha this
week in it is a retrospective of her
life and her career and at the very end
is a glamorous photo of the Queen of
Soul and a quote from her that says
simply we are require and want respect
man or woman black or white it's our
basic human
[Music]